showers continue to pivot in from the  east light shower activity but it's  right here in henderson where we  actually got a lightning strike detected  and we knew that was going to happen we  alerted to you early in social media  this is where we saw some of the heavier  rain bands and that actually gave us  about 400 of an inch of rain we'll take  anything we can get the showers still  continue to wrap around that low look at  this through kingman all coming from the  east changing over to snow in the  mountains where we certainly need it so  we're not quite done with those showers  just yet now winds did take a break but  they now have started to pick up again  look at some of these neighborhoods  north las vegas in the 20s the teens las  vegas and the teens also for nellis  temperatures are chilly outside in the  50s